[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée une nouvelle fois
au parlement européen ce mois ci nous
sommes à bruxelles de notre invité est
un habitué des couloirs ici il s'agit
d'alain lamassoure eurodéputé
franciliens membre du ppe le parti
populaire européen ensemble nous
évoquerons l'actualité brûlante du vieux
continent l'espagne l'italie la slovénie
le break site les sujets ne manquent pas
et sont inquiétants pour les européens
convaincus tout juste un an des
élections européennes en mai 2010 neuf
comme durant chaque émission nous vous
présenterons aussi le parcours d'un
personnage politique emblématique du
vieux continent aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'une femme
elle débute son quatrième mandat à la
tête de l'allemagne
anguel am merkel en fin d'émission
comparaison européenne aussi le début du
bac en france c'est dans dix jours
quelles sont les équivalents chez nos
voisins réponse en fin d'émission
[Musique]
alain lamassoure bonsoir bonsoir
quelques mots sur votre parcours pour
débuter à apprendre à vous connaître
vous avez été élue eurodéputée cinq fois
en tout la première fois c'était en 1989
il ya presque trente ans vous êtes un
fin connaisseur du vieux continent
en france vous avez été aussi ministre
d'edouard balladur et alain juppé au
milieu des années 90
ensuite en parallèle de votre mandat
européen vous avez occupé des fonctions
locales dont le sud-ouest de la france
membre de l'ump et de l erp entre 2003
et 2010 est vous avez quitté le parti en
octobre dernier sur fond de désaccord
avec la ligne adoptée face aux élus
macron compatibles comme on les appelle
vous aviez déclaré aussi récemment que
vous ne seriez pas candidat aux
prochaines élections européennes en mai
est ce que vous serez néanmoins un
observateur attentif et privilégié de
ces élections
est-ce que vous souhaiter la victoire du
camp présidentiel aujourd'hui aux
élections européennes en france ou alors
vous êtes tout de même vous allez tout
de même soutenir discrètement votre
party les républicains en france
essentiellement parti et je soutiendrai
la politique européenne du président
macron je dois dire que tous les
européens de tous les pays d'europe tous
ceux qui sont en faveur de leur souhaite
la réussite du président macron pour
réformer la france
c'est d'ailleurs l'intérêt aussi du
parti des républicains
et pour relancer l'europe et nous
attendons aujourd'hui ici au parlement
européen avec beaucoup d'intérêt le
prochain conseil européen au cours
duquel normalement emmanuel macron et
angela merkel devraient faire une série
de propositions pour relancer l'europe
alors vous êtes plutôt bienveillant
envers le président de la république
actuellement
vous avez été en revanche très critique
sur son lit des deux listes
transnationales pourquoi est-ce que
c'est pas une idée valable finalement
quand on veut créer un sentiment
européen
aujourd'hui non c'est un contresens
absolu c'est un non sens absolu
on trouve à juste titre que l'europe est
loin du citoyen est le meilleur moyen de
rapprocher l'europe des citoyens la
france par sa population a droit à 79
députés européens
le meilleur moyen serait de diviser la
france en 79 circonscription européenne
chacune élisant un ou une député
européen il soit visa le député des îles
xisha français je serais député yvelines
où les bébés nés à terme vous serez
candidat vous n'aurez pas un atlantique
est comme ça de même manière que chacun
de nous connaît son ou sa députée
nationale chacun connaît sont tous à
connaîtrait son ou sa députée européenne
ça c'est pour l'avenir un mot de
l'histoire à présent chaque mois tv 78e
vous fait découvrir celles et ceux qui
participent à la construction européenne
ce mois-ci angela merkel la chancelière
allemande est en poste en allemagne
depuis 2005 nommé 11 fois femme la plus
puissante du monde par un magazine
américain angela merkel n'a de cesse de
défendre l'union européenne
son parcours avec philippe le guen
directeur de l'association jean monnet
de bazoches sur guyonne dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
alors angela merkel elle a un parcours
assez atypique parce que elle avait
d'abord été une scientifique bon elle
vient de caler fille de pasteur et
elle a été élevée dans la partie de ces
scripts et l'allemagne de l'est donc la
république démocratique allemande
et elle avait opté pour une carrière
plutôt de scientifiques chercheurs
biologie etc est elle mal parallèlement
à ça peut-être parce qu'elle avait ceux
de son père le goût pour les choses
sociales et autres elle est toujours
restée très informés sur ce qui se
passait dans la politique et après la
chute du mur de berlin et bien elle a
orienté sa carrière plutôt vers la
politique est très jeune elle a été donc
remarqué par le parti l'a cédée ou le
parti chrétien démocrate allemand look
la droite allemande et elle a gravi
comme ça petit à petit les échelons elle
s'est trouvée au ministre
tu as ces jeunes milices de
l'environnement et de l'écologie dont
vous voyez qu'elle avait aussi un sens
se prononcer un goût prononcé pour ces
choses là ce qui explique peut-être
aujourd'hui aussi centaine décision
d'abandon du nucléaire etc
et puis là s'est fait remarquer dans le
congrès annuel du parti et petit à petit
et là elle a gravi les échelons jusqu'à
devenir ensuite alors que le chancelier
kohl l'ancien chancelier kohl petit à
petit et sortie du jeu politique
et bien elle a pris sa place finalement
elle est venue assez jeune la chef du
plus grand parti allemand est donc tout
naturellement ensuite bal est devenu
très jeunes aussi chancelière alors je
crois qu'au début en tout cas de sa
carrière elle n'était pas vraiment
spécialiste de ces questions européennes
n a pas vraiment je pense suivi le même
parcours historique que du côté de
l'allemagne de l'ouest
mais petit à petit comme elle est très
pragmatique puis c'est aussi une
caractéristique allemand balle et
devenue très européenne et elle est
devenue même aujourd'hui des personnes
les plus puissantes et plus respectée
en europe et dans le monde en tant
qu'européenne et mais je crois que ça
s'est fait de manière progressive au fil
de ces mandat de chancelière
avec aussi toutes les décisions qu'elle
a été amenée à prendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain lamassoure vous êtes-vous
eurodéputés sans discontinue depuis 1999
vous avez donc vu angela merkel grandir
politiquement sans poser dans les années
2000 devenir la leader qu'elle est
aujourd'hui qu'on connaît bien
leader quelque peu en difficulté depuis
plusieurs mois depuis sa réélection
quel regard vous portez vous sur cette
femme politique elle est admirée par
certains elle est critiquée par d'autres
quel regard vous portez vous dessus je
crois que ça a été un grand homme d'état
si je puis dire une grande femme d'état
allemandes
elle a eu la sagesse de poursuivre la
politique économique et les réformes
engagées par son prédécesseur socialiste
qui ont conduit l'allemagne à une à des
résultats économiques prodigieux
puisqu'il faut savoir que depuis trois
ans les excédents commerciaux allemands
sont supérieurs aux excédents chinois
et elle a à mes yeux eu un très grand
mérite contrairement aux reproches qui
lui sont faits ici et là aussi bien en
france qu'en allemagne
en accueillant
un million de réfugiés syriens qu'ils
fuyaient leur pays en guerre et ce
faisant elle a sauvé l'honneur de
l'europe et de notre famille politique
de centre droit européen
en traitant ce problème des réfugiés
d'abord comme un problème humanitaire
c'étaient des hommes des femmes des
enfants dont il fallait sauver la vie et
qu'on ne pouvait pas décemment en vertu
de nos valeurs laisser croupir à nos
frontières dans la boue dans le froid
sous la pluie en considérant qu'il était
indésirable chez nous un manque pas un
peu d'ambition quand même sur d'autres
sujets sur la politique européenne en
général sur sur les réfugiés beaucoup
lui ont reconnu ce point là celui que
vous saoule vié mais sur les politiques
européennes beaucoup de disques elle et
qu'elle est frileuse depuis toutes ces
années
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
ça non on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
dire ça ce qui est vrai c'est deux
choses d'abord elle est vraiment
affaiblis aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya un
an avant les élections allemandes
on espérait elle l'espérait elle le
disait que son quatrième et dernier
mandat de chancelière d'allemagne
seraient après avoir assuré le
redressement de l'allemagne consacré à
une avancée européenne forte
sauf que les élections ont été une
victoire à la pyrrhus puisque elle se
retrouve aujourd'hui à la tête d'une
coalition qui est à nouveau sur la plus
grande coalition la cdo de centre-droit
et les sociaux démocrates de centre
gauche mais les deux parties sont
affaiblis elle même
tout le monde sait que c'est la fin de
sa carrière politique
et justement de lancer des projets
qu'elle n'aurait peut-être pas osé
normand st louis mais du coup oui c'est
ce qu'on espérait mais du coup dans son
propre parti
les ambitions personnelles pour séparer
sa succession commence à apparaître et
son allié spd les socialistes qui sont
en grande coalition avec la cdu ou pour
la troisième fois qu'ils ont constaté
les deux premières fois que
électoralement le fait d'être le
partenaire junior d'une coalition plus
grande leur nuisent et leurs électeurs
se détachent deux sont entrés dans cette
troisième grande coalition
à reculons et avec la l'intention de ne
pas y faire grand chose ce qui fait que
le président macron qui veut faire
beaucoup de choses pour l'europe va
devoir faire preuve de beaucoup
d'éloquence pour convaincre les
allemandes d'aller plus loin elle semble
quand même un petit peu bougé sur le sur
le sujet là est là elle a répondu à une
interview récemment d'un journal
allemand où elle a elle elle a dit oui
pour pour un budget de la zone euro même
si celui ci est trop petit pour certains
trop trop faible oui aussi à la création
d'un fonds monétaire européen
oui pour la création d'une force commune
d'intervention en matière de sécurité
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
aussi pour l'europe ça ou alors c'est
trop peu encore trop peu et ça ne répond
pas assez aux besoins de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui c'est trop peu
mais là je dirai si le président macron
de jouer et
je ne suis pas en accord avec sa
priorité actuelle et vous voyez lui sa
priorité c'est la zone euro rend
forcément euros je crois que ça c'était
un objectif
hier la zone euro elle est forte elle
existe depuis 20 ans dans la période
2010 2011 2012
elle a survécu à trois années pendant
laquelle tous les jours tous les marchés
financiers ont spéculé sur son excuse on
est carrément sur la grèce sur l'espagne
et sur l'italie est la sentence a tout
naturellement c'est pas une zone
parfaite
il ya des ajustements à faire mais ça ça
relève des mini des finances c'est plus
aux grands chefs d'état salle occupée
ce dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
l'urgence d'aujourd'hui et ce à tous nos
concitoyens le comprends c'est la
sécurité la sécurité d'europe la
sécurité intérieure face au terrorisme
face au grand banditisme face aux
pressions migratoires la sécurité
extérieure face aux extravagances du
président poutine au désintérêt que marc
le président train pour la sécurité de
l'europe
et puis à toutes ces crises qui sont
près de nous les guerres civiles du
moyen-orient et puis à plus long terme
l'émergence de l'afrique est à la fois
pour nous une formidable opportunité
et si on le gère mal une formidable
menaces sur tous ces sujets une large
majorité de nos compatriotes dans tous
les sondages y compris une majorité des
électeurs du front national ou de la
france insoumise reconnaissent que si on
n'agit pas au niveau européen on se sent
impuissant et donc moi la place du
président macron au lieu d' ennuyer les
allemands avec le peaufinage de la zone
euro
je proposerai aux allemands et à tous
nos partenaires de bâtir maintenant
l'europe de la sécurité il faut il faut
il faut dire aux européens qu'on les
protège c'est ça l'objectif
selon vos propos oui le premier besoin
dans une communauté politique c'est la
sécurité
or cette sécurité elle n'est plus
assurée aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
grandes menaces extérieures nous avons
vécu dans l'idée que tout ça sur les
américains seraient là sauf que la
guerre froide est finie depuis 20 ans
nos intérêts de sécurité sont plus les
mêmes que ceux les américains je prends
un exemple l'iran le président entrant
peut se permettre de déchirer les
accords signés avec l'iran il s'en fiche
aucun missile iranien ne peut frapper
les états unis les iraniens ont d'ores
et déjà des missiles qui peuvent frapper
l'europe
et si ces missiles ont une tête
nucléaire pour nous c'est un problème
tragique
si les américains veulent pas s'en
occuper et on le comprend d'une certaine
manière c'est à nous européens de nous
en occuper
la france tout seul ne peut pas elle n'a
pas de raison de le faire l'allemagne
tout seul ne peut pas bien entendu les
autres pays tout seuls ne peuvent pas
non plus nous devons le faire tous
ensemble
et face aux problèmes migratoires qui
crée des divisions politiques un malaise
dans tous nos pays
il est évident que cet ensemble en
renforçant
là nos frontières extérieures communes
mais aussi en ayant dans nos 27 pays
désormais les mêmes règles sur les
conditions d'entrée de circulation de
séjour de travail des étrangers venus de
ports d'europe que nous pourrons
maîtriser le problème alors juste pour
évoquer un sujet qui vous est cher
actuellement c'est la fiscalité angela
merkel n'a rien dit de dessus dans son
dans sa précédente interview vous
travaillez soit un projet d'assiette
commune consolidée de l'impôt sur les
sociétés ça peut paraître un peu barbare
comme ça de prime abord est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire en quelques mots de
quoi il s'agit en quoi c'est important
par exemple pour l'union européenne de
demain alors ça tous les auditeurs dont
on parle de quoi il s'agit nous sommes
en période de déclaration des revenus
imposables
j' y ai qu il ya quelques jours remplis
ma déclaration papier maintenant on est
dans la période de déclaration par
internet nous payons tous nos impôts
individuel ou entreprises pme et nous
avons appris à la faveur malheureusement
de scandales comme luxe fixe que
quelques unes
plusieurs dizaines des plus grandes
multinationales mondiales
les américaines mais aussi des
européennes y compris les françaises se
débrouiller en jouant des différences de
nos systèmes fiscaux à l'inter d'union
européenne pour échapper à 98% 99 % de
l'impôt qu'elles devraient payer sur
leurs bénéfices
le seul moyen d'éviter cette situation
absolument intolérable
et en même temps d'assurer des
conditions de concurrence égales de ce
point de vue fondamental entre nos
entreprises de tous les pays européens
de tous les secteurs de toutes les
tailles
c'est d'avoir le même impôt sur les
sociétés dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne
et ça vous vous pensez que ça va être
fait à court terme puisque je crois que
le sujet est en discussion depuis les
années 2000 est ce que c'est que c'est
un projet qui peut des trades j'avais
fait partie de ceux qui avaient lancé
l'idée est qu'elle avait fait accepter
le principe d'ailleurs il y a 20 ans et
ce projet a eu des hauts et des bas
depuis il ya eu les scandales il a fallu
les scandales et ça bouge vraiment ah
ben ça bouge vraiment parce que sous la
pression de l'opinion publique
sous la pression des médias et là je
rends hommage au journaliste
d'investigation qui ont constitué un
consortium qui ont fait ces enquêtes et
qui ont sorti luc slicks scandale
offshore l'x les paradise papers les
panama papers et cetera il y a
maintenant les pressions de l'opinion
publique pour qu'on mette fin à cette
situation et des pressions des
entreprises avec le soutien des
syndicats pour que nous ayons le même
système dans l'union européenne si le
président macron en fait sa priorité
ça pourra avancer que veut arriver à un
accord des 27 pays avant la fin de
l'année 2018 un mot sur l'actualité avec
la décision de donald trump est des
états unis de taxer l'acier et
l'aluminium européen
une plainte a été déposée par par
l'union européenne auprès de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce omc
une réponse est attendue aussi pour
imposer des taxes européennes sur les
produits américains on attend une
liste détaillée d'ici les prochains
jours faut-il taper fort sur les
etats-unis aujourd'hui après cette
décision de donald trump est ce que vous
rendre cucurrucucu pour coup il ne faut
pas se lancer dans une escalade les
guerres commerciales et états unis
ça ne date pas de tram nous en avons
connu beaucoup n'a pas pris une nouvelle
tournure avec le président américain
j'apprends une cure une tournure de
d'auteur de tweets l'acier et
l'aluminium
c'est des matières c'est très peu pour
les ornières importante
évidemment pour l'industrie mais en été
en termes de valeur c'est très très peu
et donc
le président train devait être soumis à
une réélection de son parlement en
novembre prochain déjà ce qu'on appelle
les élections de mi parcours les midterm
élections donc il fait d'électoralisme
en tapant sur les européens et sur ses
voisins immédiats d'un canadien et et le
mexique
c'est une bêtise économique politique
son nom il faut que l'on reprenne un peu
de hauteur ne répond pas forcer si si il
faut il faut que le nom au contraire
trompé d'un homme qui ne comprend que
les rapports de force
donc si on lui dit oui ou si on ne
réagit pas à ce moment-là il en
rajoutera une couche la fois d'après par
contre il faut pas encourager
l'escaladent parce que là on pourrait
arriver à une véritable guerre
commerciale et leurs lacets du perdant
perdant pour tout le monde ça serait
absolument ridicule
bon il nous tape il faut répondre de la
même manière c'est ce que d'ailleurs
nous avons prévu de faire
est ce que l'union européenne doit faire
le deuil de sa relation transatlantique
particulier avec les états unis selon
vous en tout cas sous la présidence
trump pour les prochaines années ce
qu'on doit se dire ça y est c'est un nom
il faut jouer il faut jouer à long terme
il était nous avons commis une erreur en
ne poussant pas les feux sur un grand
projet de traité transatlantique qui
était représenté par les initiales type
il ya quelques années du temps du
président obama et à l'époque une partie
des harkis politiques français notamment
l'extrême droite et les partis de gauche
ont fait campagne sur le thème ah non du
coup les méchants capitalistes
américains vont nous imposer leurs
normes ray société semblait assez arc
bouté sur ce il y avait deux civils un
certain nombre de ng se prétendant
représentants de la société civile et
jouant de la désinformation sur ces
sujets or l'enjeu était considérable
s'était se mettre d'accord et américains
sur un certain nombre de normes communes
de normes politiques droits de l'homme
démocratie
de normes économiques et techniques mais
aussi de normes sociales et
environnementales qui soient les nôtres
et qui soient pas systématiquement les
normes américaines et 6e
nous avions été capables de faire cela
dit nous sommes capable un jour de faire
cela alors les normes occidentales
deviendront tout naturellement les
normes du reste du monde tant que nous
ne le faisons pas et si nous tardons
trop longtemps à le faire c'est bien
nous constaterons en enchaînant sa soeur
des normes chinoises ce sera des normes
russes et ça sera au fond la loi de la
jungle à laquelle on reviendra parce que
pour ces pays
il n'y a pas de norme internationale qui
compte la seule chose qu'ils connaissent
et les rapports de force est
malheureusement le président trump là
dessus a fait un retour en arrière
considérable alors que les états unis
jusqu'à lui était le symbole dans le
monde du multilatéralisme et des
relations pacifiques entre état reposant
sur des règles de droit et des contrats
il revient à son tour au rapport de
force
on passe à présent à notre rubrique et
chez nos voisins ça se passe comment à
quelques jours de la première épreuve du
baccalauréat ce sera la philosophie le
lundi 18 juin prochain intéressons nous
à cet examen le bac à la française
semble unique en europe
mel est il vraiment quelles sont ces
équivalences en europe ont fait le point
avec olivier chanut ex responsable du
centre europe direct à saint germain en
laye
tous les pays de l'union européenne ont
un diplôme qui permet de sanctionner la
fin des études dans le domaine du
secondaire alors après la forme que ça
prend va dépendre du pays
certains états ont décidé de ne pas
avoir de bach c'est notamment le cas de
la suède ou en fait c'est un contrôle
continu qui prend les notes de la
dernière année au lycée
la plupart des états ont mis en place un
système mixte ou en fait on mélange une
partie de contrôle continu et une partie
des profits finale donc on a notamment
le cas de l'allemagne avec le habits
tour qui est l'équivalent de
l'équivalent allemand du bac ou en fait
le contrôle continu compte pour deux
tiers des notes du bac et on a enfin
certains états qui comme la france et
l'irlande avec le living certificates
ont décidé de maintenir en place un
système qui est principalement basé sur
des épreuves finales le bac d'un état
peuvent être reconnus dans un autre état
membre de l'union européenne tout dépend
à près de ce qui est prévu par la
législation nationale
pour simplifier il existe on va dire
qu'il existe deux grandes formalité la
première formalité il s'agit de il
s'agit d'un dossier d'inscription ou en
fait concrètement on va demander
notamment à faire traduire le bac
le pack d'un état à le faire traduire
par un traducteur assermenté c'est
notamment le cas lorsqu'un étudiant
français souhaitent s'inscrire en
allemagne dans d'autres pays notamment
si on a envie d'aller étudier au royaume
uni il faut faire une équivalence c'est
à dire qu'il faut 30 dont il faut grosso
modo transformer son bac c'est
ce son bac en équivalent du bac locale
afin de pouvoir candidater afin de
pouvoir candidater dans l'enseignement
supérieur les autorités européenne
travaille à une meilleure reconnaissance
des diplômes nationaux notamment dans le
cadre de la réforme lmd licence master
doctorat
sachant que après certains états ont
décidé de prendre le problème de ces de
se saisir eux-mêmes du problème et de
mettre en place on va dire des centres
de bach bilatéraux ou en fait on peut
passer un bac dans un état et ce bac va
être valable dans certains pays par
exemple en france on a le cas de
l'abibac qui permet d'avoir en même
temps le habits tour allemand et le bac
français ainsi que le bachibac qui
permet d'avoir donc en même temps le bac
français et le basque espagnol
[Musique]
alain lamassoure le bac ça vous évoque
quoi pour vous alors là on change
complètement de sujets c'est très
anciens excusez moi pour vous forcément
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque comme
souvenir peut-être est la période où il
y avait un bac différents tous les ans
et moi j'ai passé un bac qui n'a eu lieu
sous cette forme qu'une seule fois dans
l'histoire dans lequel on commençait le
bac est en deux parties
première partie à la fin de la 1ère 2ème
partie à la fin un terminal bon çà çà çà
a eu lieu plusieurs années mais la
première partie commençait par des
étoiles en février qui n'était valable
que si on avait dans les matières où on
avait la moyenne donc on arrivait en
février en voilà on arrivait en février
assez décontracté puisque on ne voulait
pas perdre du coup on se comportait bien
on avait les moyens de partout et du
coup c'était plus facile pour tout le
monde alors le bac en france permet
évidemment d'accéder aux études
supérieures l'actualité c'est aussi
parcours sub quel regard vous portez
vous sur cette plate forme système juste
et efficace pour vous une sélection
malheureuse comme certains le dénonce
certes système évidemment plus juste
moins injuste plus efficaces au moins
efficace que le système précédent que
personne ne pouvait justifier qui est
actuellement honteux
bon je reste persuadé qu'il faut arriver
à avoir le courage de faire une
sélection c'est la dernière
bien entendu mais bien entendu bien
entendu il faut éviter que des jeunes
perdent leur temps et leur argent en se
lançant dans des études
auxquels ils ont accès parce qu'il n'ya
pas de sélection mais dont il se rend
compte au bout d'un an deux ou trois
coeurs étaient ils sont pas faits pour
ça c'est c'est un formidable gâchis
merci alain lamassoure d'avoir participé
à ce 7,8 europe je rappelle que vous
êtes eurodéputés franciliens membre du
ppe la droite européenne vous est même
le vice président de la délégation
française du ppe merci également aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
à bruxelles vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet est là commenté sur nos réseaux
sociaux tv soixante dix huit la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez le 7-8
politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]